doing a lot of we're doing a lot of
streams but it's just the date so like
if you're wondering what day or what
stuff that i talked about or trying to
find the tweets
for that day you just type in the date
now what it is is the year the last
number of the year the month and then
the day
and then you know what what bite so if
you're looking for it i'm just letting
you know
if you want you probably don't give a
[ __ ] does anyone give a [ __ ] no one
gives a [ __ ] okay let's move on tony we
are at 48 minutes
into the hour
oh here's the uh the [ __ ] clip of
of uh scab face
scab
scab bannon
the the cool water
he's uh patriotic says he's he has hired
a legal team that is set to go on
offense uh i don't know if you guys
heard this but the legal team that this
[ __ ] [ __ ] box has hired is the same
[ __ ] box that defended trump in the
second impeachment trial
of course you know that was
as a [ __ ] kangaroo court there too i
mean jesus christ it was rigged because
these republicans are too terrified to
devote him out
especially at the end oh we get we got
so many days left to leave this
dangerous maniac as president nothing
could go wrong not a goddamn thing
not like uh you know what happened in
january 6. you know they left him in for
several days after you know
[ __ ] idiots anyway spiro agnew's
ghost says ah yes they will invoke the
hobo podcast host clause of executive
privilege the hobo podcast host clause
god damn it spirit agnew's ghost i take
offense to that
i don't i don't know if i'm exactly a
hobo but yeah i got the beard my hair is
getting long
um but and this it's so dumb it's
exactly like trump saying his combos
with a hot dog vendor are privileged
this is really [ __ ] stupid this
executive privilege [ __ ] where they're
like oh we were committing crimes but i
was committing crimes with the president
united states so it's executive
privilege like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about just because you utter
words to the person who holds the office
of the the president united states does
not mean they're privileged
like that that's not what that means
that's not what it means it's [ __ ]
really stupid now let's give spirit
agnes um
ghost credit here
and and we read it so we give it credit
and then let's get patriot takes let's
go listen to the the video and we'll
we'll listen to this [ __ ]
scab-face skank
tell us scat scab-face skank steve
bannon holy [ __ ] did i just come up with
a new nickname for this [ __ ]
scaffa skank
he's a scab face skank tweet that [ __ ]
out tweet it out if you're out there go
tweet it right now
hashtag scab face skank steve bannon
that's a really long hashtag by the way
maybe maybe i'm maybe i'm not as good as
i think with the beard build back build
black butter bill bill but better be
better back bitter build back back build
better back
yeah okay let's
let's listen to the the scat base game
took on the wrong irishman here right oh
yeah because
the irish are born fighting like scots
and uh we're gonna we're gonna get very
engaged here i tired you notice how he's
he tries to play this white heritage
[ __ ] and do what he's trying to like
he's some kind of tough guy because he's
and what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i i've met a lot of irish people and
some of them are really [ __ ] tough
but they're them being irish had nothing
to do with them being tough
they're just tough because they're
[ __ ] tough what are you talking about
a legal team that is set to go on
offense and they're just not going to
sit there and and take what do you mean
go on offense what the [ __ ] could pot
what the [ __ ] offense could you have
possibly have when you're the defendant
these people these people really do love
gaslighting their sheep
they really i mean they [ __ ] love it
they [ __ ] they i i actually sometimes
believe that it ain't actually about
them taking over and [ __ ] it's about how
what can we get these [ __ ] people to
believe
can we get them to believe that they're
that we're not the defendant we're the
offended offensive we're on offense baby
what are you talking about you just got
[ __ ] indicted and charged with
criminal cri with federal crimes
criminal contempt of congress which is a
year in jail
and up to like a ten thousand dollar
fine i think which should be way more
than that
but that that
what are you talking about you're on the
offense what are you gonna are you gonna
charge them are you gonna you gonna
arraign the prosecutor that's that ain't
how it [ __ ] works dummy you you're
charged by a grand jury
you [ __ ] bonehead oh my god these
[ __ ] people and then what's crazy is
steve bannon is saying this he knows
that's not the [ __ ] real you know
there's not an offense when you're the
defense
he's he's gaslighting these [ __ ] that's
why he says the irish thing he tries to
bring it back to but what he's saying is
white he's saying white there that's
what he's meaning that's that's what
that means like white guy to white guy
that's what that means when a white
person is talking about where you know
where they're from
from from ireland or scotland or
somewhere in europe they're talking
about their [ __ ] skin color that's
what they're saying they're they're
white take this nonsense uh from the us
attorneys and from uh and from merrick
garland's it's not gonna happen we're
going on offense
the nonsense from merrick garland the
nine cents is not from merrick garland
you dumb [ __ ] the the
disappointment is it took merrick
garland to convene a grand jury and
convince him to charge you
it took three [ __ ] weeks
that's one disappointment it shouldn't
have took that long the congress really
honestly i in my opinion they shouldn't
[ __ ] convene the grand jury [ __ ] that
grand jury they had a vote for criminal
contempt from congress that's your grand
jury you don't need any more than that
congress gets to decide when you're held
in contempt
congress it's congress that gets to
decide when you're held in contempt
they get to [ __ ] decide so they
decided and they voted on it my opinion
is merrick garland waited way too long
and they can meet a grand jury now my
hope is is that grand jury is going to
continue to see these cases on these
criminal contempts because the the the
the the going uh um
uh narrative here is that uh jeffrey
clark mark meadows he's all all these
people are gonna be held in criminal
contempt
this is just
this [ __ ] scab face skink scat face
skank
i'm no longer no longer is he sloppy
steve
he is scab faced skank
scabbed face skank
okay
he is a scab face gank though isn't he
right
am i wrong am i right uh back to the uh
the written house actually ben uh my
zealous
of legal af um gives his his little two
cents here he says very weak closing for
the defense
scripted and
stilted
very strong closing and rebuttal by
prosecution
in the hands of the jury
and this is the point this is the other
point where you're like whoa what the
[ __ ] did he say you know we just seen
the video where he's talking about
uh how many times someone shot and got
away with it and then uh it should be
okay the kyle written shot someone four
times because someone else has shot
someone seven times and got away with it
so it's okay
but here he says i'm glad he shot him
when he's talking about this joseph
rosenbaum like that guy's a [ __ ]
scumbag and i'm glad he's dead i'm glad
he shot him see and this is the
difference between some of the right and
some of the quote unquote left or i
would just say reasonable people in this
country when you're talking about the
death penalty like look someone breaks
into your house and tries to steal your
tv
that it shouldn't be caused to shoot and
kill them like stealing a tv the
punishment is not death
and really we shouldn't have the death
penalty in this country we should we
should lead the death penalty
for i mean literally it it should be
like huge headline news
like once in every 10 years that someone
actually receives a death penalty in
this country
this this it should be reserved for the
the lowest of the lowest of the low
and and without reason with with no
reasonable doubt that we have to have
that we can [ __ ] the government can
murder somebody can kill them could take
their life
otherwise yeah it's our responsibility
to see justice and lock them up
for whatever the punishment but we
should be cheering people shooting other
people no matter what they've done
this this is this is this narrative of
political violence this is we're glad
they shot him because
of his political beliefs or whatever
whatever the [ __ ] you know oh rosenbaum
was a criminal and he was on their side
or whatever the narrative is you see
this political violence thing playing
out um in this whole kyle rittenhouse
trial but let's let's let's listen to
this [ __ ] idiot stupid [ __ ] kyle shot
joseph rosenbaum to stop a threat to his
person and i'm glad he shot him because
if joseph rosenbaum had got that gun i
don't for a minute believe he wouldn't
have used it against somebody else he
was irrational
and oh [ __ ] crazy
i'm glad he shot him
we here on the defense believe that my
client
my client not only shot and killed that
[ __ ] but we're glad he shot and
killed that [ __ ] dead yeah
and uh
we love the cookies that the judge
ordered us we love those cookies thanks
judge thanks judge thanks for the
cookies
oh did i give credit here for ben oh my
god we read it and we didn't give credit
now now we're we did gave credit and we
also got to give credit
to the recount for the video thank you
recap for the footage there
for the clip
we are 58 minutes and a half minutes
into the hour we do an hour here i'm so
glad you you joined us oh i want to read
this tweet
this is [ __ ] hilarious
uh connect politic ditto
see politic ditto
right this is [ __ ] hilarious
so it's it's biden signing the
infrastructure bill right and he says
dear donald
happy infrastructure week you punk-ass
[ __ ]
sincerely brandon
i love it
i love it
this is a big victory and we need to run
victory laps and you know what you know
what we need to do we need to leave
[ __ ]
a track shoe prints all over manga the
republicans and maga wanted one in
infrastructure for four years and
democrats would have delivered it
do not get this twisted people
democrats would have delivered donald
trump an infrastructure bill
just as much or more money
than the infrastructure bill
that president joe biden signed
yesterday 100 percent democrats would do
the right thing in this country do the
right thing for the democracy do the
right thing for the american people and
they would have delivered to trump's
desk and infrastructure bill
100
because that is the difference between
the two parties
is they see they see success for the
american people as a success for the
american people
republicans see success for the american
people when democrats do it as treason
that's the truth
so yeah dear donald happy infrastructure
week you punk ass [ __ ]
sincerely brandon i love it
all right all right um and we're not i'm
not going to play the do you guys want
to see the [ __ ] ingram clip where
she's like who's on first what's on
second i don't know who's on third let's
go watch it uh gabe here writes and
laura ingraham wait wait wait when did i
mention measles
oh it was on you
what's on me
this is really [ __ ] stupid again this
is like the who's on first the modern
day who's on first
give great gabe credit here for his
tweet we read it we gotta we gotta we
gotta give credit but here's the [ __ ]
the stupid video to the politics and all
those here's the video
of this [ __ ] clip i i i actually
think [ __ ] this is to the politics and
all those woke story lines in so many
shows today you know i was watching the
woke storylines
you where measles came up
wait wait when did i mention measles
i don't know
it was
what was on me what are you talking
about right what is
you know what is so frustrating about
this is people again they think she's
[ __ ] dumb here she's not [ __ ] dumb
she's she's not even playing dumb here
she's doing what she always does
she's doing what she always does this is
what she does on any [ __ ] issue
anywhere
race
social issues
uh um when you're talking about
government spending when you're talking
about anything really this is what she
does she she does this stupid [ __ ]
snarky thing where she's acting like she
doesn't know and then she's gonna know
watch what's on you
we never did
we never did a measles and vaccine
episode is this a joke i don't even know
what you're talking about it was on you
it was on youtube i've never had raymond
i've never had measles what are you
talking about this is stupid it was an
episode of a show laura
what's it called you
you it's called you i've never done a
show on measles i i just completely give
up we gotta get it it's a show i give up
called you on netflix
there's a show called lowering on
netflix
i'm moving on to adele i can't explain
this to you
[ __ ] boneheads
see see you you made me in my [ __ ] now i
gotta go find something else because i'm
not i'm not in the show oh here's george
carlin's trending again let's go find
something in this thread
that uh
that
is worth seeing
i can't i can't [ __ ] do it i can't
listen that
that [ __ ] white supremacist nazi
pretend like she doesn't know
what he was talking about
[Music]
we already watched that one uh we
watched that one we watched that one
let's
come on
there's got to be a good carlin clip
here this clip is going crazy
um
let's see
oh here's one i posted here you go here
you go so you remember uh mike flynn
talking about religion right right he's
talking about religion oh we need one
religion in this country and it's q anon
we all need to go down to dallas and
wait for jfk junior to show up so we can
worship trump or some dumb [ __ ] i don't
know
if you're standing around in your
trump-humping proud boy uniform
wondering why george carlin would would
what george garland would say about mike
flynn and christianity you weren't
paying attention
major league [ __ ] this is uh one of
one of george garland's takes on
religion let's listen to that and then
we'll throw the show out i gotta tell
you the truth when it comes to [ __ ]
big time
major league [ __ ] you have to stand
in awe
in awe of the all-time champion of false
promises and exaggerated claims religion
no contest
no
contest
religion
religion easily has the greatest
[ __ ] story ever told
think about it religion has actually
convinced people
that there's an invisible man
living in the sky
who watches everything you do every
minute of every day and the invisible
man has a special list of 10 things he
does not want you to do
and if you do any of these ten things he
has a special place full of fire and
smoke and burning and torture and
anguish where he will send you to live
and suffer and burn and choke and scream
and cry forever and ever till the end of
time
but he loves you
he loves you
he's one of the best friends
he loves you and he needs money
he always needs money that broke
[ __ ] awful all perfect
all-knowing and all wise somehow
just can't handle money
religion takes in billions of dollars
they pay no taxes and they always need a
little more yeah now you talk about a
good [ __ ] story
holy [ __ ]
one of the best uh religion bits by
george carlin
um and i i will say back to the reason
why i posted this the reason why i
picked this one out was that um
you know this is this is their grift
this is the mike flynn grift of one
religion they're raising
mountains of money off this q and on
stuff because these [ __ ] sheeple are
believing this [ __ ] garbage and
they're continuing to believe this
[ __ ] garbage and and they will
continue to believe it
the reason why is that there are [ __ ]
pictures
of these people still down in dallas
waiting on jfk junior to show up on an
alien spaceship or some dumb [ __ ] i
don't i don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] they're waiting on i have no idea i
don't know what's hap i don't know what
they think's gonna happen
but this is what he's talking about they
believe
they believe oh there's a spaghetti
monster in the sky this invisible thing
that controls everything
any any he's and if you're bad he'll
burn you
in this deep deep hole inside the earth
or wherever
but he loves you and oh yeah he needs he
needs money he needs money just like
just like trump needs money just like
mike flynn needs money just like q anon
needs money they all need money and
you're gonna have to buy their hat their
chinese made hats and chinese printed
flags and all this [ __ ] that's made in
china and they claim to be patriots and
american and all this [ __ ] and
they're gonna gaslight you the whole
[ __ ] way and steal your [ __ ]
money right out of your [ __ ] bank
account
the whole [ __ ] way
while you're waiting on jfk to show up
they'll they'll make sure
they'll make sure they they pick your
[ __ ] pocket
well thank you for joining me on the
shitless round up here today oh [ __ ]
list
come back tomorrow
at noon eastern 11 central
for the [ __ ] list roundup and also
tomorrow we have the podcast on we got a
very
very good podcast tomorrow i will tell
you tomorrow we are going to a two hour
format we're gonna go to two hour format
cause we're gonna have a guest on every
single week during our normal hour our
normal show it's going to start the same
time same place nothing's changing about
um the actual time that it's going to
start it's just going to be a little
longer so you get a little more you get
a little more
instead of having the special guest
episode on friday some of you some of
you out there in the audience know we
have a special guest episode on friday
every once in a while we're kind of
bringing that special guest episode into
the episode
every single week so every single week
we're going to have a guest on the
podcast and this week this week we have
two guests that you are not going to
want to miss i'm going to announce it on
on twitter this afternoon so be paying
attention this afternoon on twitter be
paying attention to some of those
announcements about the podcast tomorrow
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern youtube twitter twitch you can
download it on apple spotify google
go over there and download the old
episodes ketchup get caught up or
mustard whichever ketchup mustard that's
my dad joke of the day so ending on the
dad joke
we'll see you tomorrow surf's up
surf's up [ __ ]